[Music]
hello and welcome back to the endgame
class as always my name is caleb denby
and today i wanted to talk to you guys a
little bit about everybody's least
favorite end games the opposite colored
bishop and game
and um i wanted to start with the
bare bare bones of this one and
specifically we're going to get into
what happens
when one side has two extra pawns
because
as you can see on the board here if we
flip to it one pawn
is just never going to be enough and i
think most players are familiar with
this
idea so how does white actually draw
these positions
well of course first and foremost
uh you can always sacrifice the bishop
for the pawn if you
are in the pure end game but even if you
add two extra pawns over here
white always has this idea to blockade
what idea to blockade i hear you ask
well even if
white was you know not allowed to
capture the black pieces for whatever
reason
you can just keep the king on e2 forever
and ever and ever
and no matter what black tries you can
never force this king off of e2
white will always pass back and forth
forever with the bishop
and the game would be declared a draw
and so that's why you see
a lot of these opposite colored bishop
end games just you know outright being
drawn but
the plot thickens a little bit if you
add in a
second pawn so does anyone in the chat
know the objective
evaluation of this position really of
most positions almost all positions
where one side
has two connected past pawns
who knows this one who can tell me does
white
draw does black win what's the idea here
what is the idea
nightmare says draw peter peterson says
still draw
patrick says two connected in the middle
of the board is
winning somebody somewhere says black
win plays it
says draw great wolf says draw
peter says sack the bishop for the two
pawns easy
chess king says draw blockade patrick
says white can't stack for both black
can win
so of course black can win but black
should not win because this position
is technically a draw how is it a draw
well white can set up a very specific
type of fortress
now if you know the position should be a
draw but you don't know this idea
i think more often than not black does
actually end up winning these games
and so let's take a look and get into
the nitty-gritty here and see what this
fortress
idea is for white well first of all i
kind of want to show you
what not to do so let's start with king
d2 this move is fine
something like d5 king e3 still this is
all fine
let's say king d7 advancing the king we
get tempted to give a check so we go
bishop b5 check
king d6 and let's try
challenging these pawns from behind so
what do you guys think about challenging
the pawns from behind
good or bad idea for white
good or bad to challenge the pawns from
behind you tell me a chat room
chess king says bad great wolf says bad
very bad bad good says manny manny going
against the grain
i appreciate that i appreciate that
patrick has no idea
bad i said so i did kind of spoil this
one apologies so
attacking the pawns from behind believe
it or not i think this is the more
natural way to go after the pawns right
the pawns attack forward that's scary
attacking them from the front what are
you insane they might take you
attacking from them from behind on the
surface does look to be
like the safer option but actually
this is quite seriously just the wrong
way to go about things
why is that well black is going to push
the the pawn that you're not attacking
always trying to keep the pawns on light
squares and we'll look at why in a
second
and then if you try to blockade the king
just starts to advance
and we see that this is not
going to be an acceptable blockade and
we'll look at why this
particular idea is losing a little bit
more in depth in just a moment
but let's talk about what would be a
draw right so first and foremost
this one is obviously a draw why is that
well white can blockade either on e4 or
d3
and now all white has to do is pass back
and forth with the bishop
somewhere along this diagonal always
making sure that these two pieces
are defending the e4 square together so
that's important to note
if white can set up this light square
blockade then it is
just a draw but if white can't then of
course
black can sometimes win so let's go back
to this position
we saw check king here let's say bishop
a6
check king d2 so how can black win this
position
who knows how can black win this
position
or is this a fortress
chess king says king f4 king f3
manny says bishop h6 so i mean these are
these are great ideas
but you know what is the goal that
you're working towards let's let's agree
on what the goal is
and then we'll talk about how to
actually get there
what's the goal here
there's something that black should be
fighting for
promote the e pawn while a little bit
more
a little bit more attainable
chess king wants to play e3 with the
king on f3
i am gonna have to disagree with you
there i have to disagree remember we're
not trying to get the pawns to dark
squares that's very very easy
trying to get the pawns to light squares
so let's say king f4 and i allow you to
play king f3
and i pass and you play e3 i think this
is just a draw
right just to draw here i get my light
squared blockade
even if i was not in time to stop you
from coming to e4
go king e2 and again we have our draw so
e3
is not the idea we're playing for
the move we are fighting for is of
course d3
this is the first step in our process
right you can't think of your goal as to
clean the pawns of course that's your
goal
but you have to get there one step at a
time and that next step is d3
so what's stopping us from playing d3
right now well of course
white would capture the pawn right and
then this would be
a draw because there are no pawns left
but
black can actually manufacture a way to
play d3
without allowing white to sacrifice the
the bishop for both of the pawns so how
do we achieve this
that's why i want to play bishop h6 move
the king away so you can start with
bishop h6 but what if king e2
what if king e2 here right
now how do you win
get the king to c3 how
how if you go king d5 i'll check you
i'll check you
king d5 i check you
so arion has the right first move which
is of course not to step to d5
when you do get checked and have to
return but you can actually step to d6
and then as you guys in the chat room
are saying
you are correct you get the king to c3
and once the king arrives on c3 of
course the
pawn to d3 idea is going to come through
and work
and if white tries to step around to
stop you then d3
is just quite strong immediately so
white would have to pass if you go here
again d3 check is good enough
so pass king c5 king b4
again if you go here just d3 check
and e3 saves the pawn just because the
king's far away doesn't mean you get to
take that guy for free
and so uh well actually yeah white would
be unable to pass along
this diagonal anyways here but even if
he could then king c3
is good enough because d3 is unstoppable
so attacking the pawns from behind
doesn't work
so what does work well of course this is
hacking the pawns from the front
so who can tell me why attacking the
pawns from the front
is a drawing idea for white
why does it draw why does attacking the
pawns from the front
work to draw the game who can tell me
let's say for example bishop g2 king
here let's say pass e5 why is white
drawing this game
why is white drawing the game here
blockade on the light square well that's
what we tried to do last time right we
tried to
set up for the bishop we were guarding
from a6
all the way down hold on other other way
how do i do this
yeah a6 all the way down to f1 look at
me go figuring out the angles
but somehow the king made its way around
and was able to support the pawn push
so what is stopping black from bringing
the king around
and supporting the pawn bush
so k name has the right idea the huge
trick to having the bishop in front of
the pawn
is that we can both stop the pawn from
advancing
we're pressuring the e4 square so this
pawn can't advance
but in addition to that we are at the
same time attacking the d5 pawn and this
is the critical thing here
because now black is unable to bring the
king around to f4
in order to support the e4 push because
as soon as he leaves
he's going to be leaving the d5 pawn
behind
and black is just simply unable to make
progress here
just unable to make progress
and this is the crux of the idea of the
opposite color bishop
end game against two connected pawns
white must
guard the pawns from the front but it's
not so easy to just remember that
arbitrarily
but if you remember why it's because we
need to both pressure
the square in front of the pawn and the
other pawn
itself to make sure the pawns cannot
advance
this is the critical idea to draw the
game
uh here so let me ask you a question
let's say we had
just for example just for example we had
this position we had this position
is this game a dead draw is this game a
dead draw
we're guarding the pawns from the front
but is this game a dead draw
no why not why is this game not drawn
what can black do
what can black do to try to progress
so yes black can progress because we
don't have the pressure on the d5 pawn
now as black winning actually black is
not winning just yet because blight
still has an opportunity to set up a
blockade
but for example bishop h6 check
and king f3 trying to keep an eye on
this now all of a sudden
you are powerless to stop king d4 and
e4 check but now of course after king a2
because black still has one more step to
get across
with uh d5 to d4 to d3
white is still drawing the game because
now we do have pressure on
this pawn but not because of any funny
bishop a2 ideas
just because we were far enough up the
board that we have a second chance to
make our blockade
but important to note here very
important to note
that you need the pressure on the pawn
to make sure that the game isn't isn't
lost
so by the way i want to introduce some
tricky tricks here
i think i can come up with some tricky
tricks something
like king to c3 right king to c3
is a very tricky move so king to c3
white to move and draw and these are
dangers that you
start running into if you let the pawns
come too far down the board
black and start playing some tricky
business
so yes of course bishop a2 would lose
the game because now after d4
bishop b1 we are not getting both pawns
but king d1 is good enough when now
we have pressure on this pawn preventing
this pawn from advancing
but hold on what if i pass what if i
pass
now what now what's
well of course as i'm sure people in the
chat are going to say when they see
the answer is bishop c2 if you go king
e2 then king b2 and this bishop is
unfortunately trapped very unfortunately
trapped
um and yeah that's i think pretty much
the the only real trick here
i'm trying to think if they're there
anymore but i think this is about the
only thing to look out for
so this is i think by far the trickiest
of the draws
for the opposite color bishop end games
when you are facing
two connected past pawns it's very
important to remember to defend against
the pawns from the front
and not just because you know the front
is better it's because you need to
pressure the square in front of the pawn
and the backwards pawn at the same time
to ensure that the king
cannot roam his way around the board and
support the the push of the pawns and of
course there is the idea that everybody
knows
which is this idea of
the the light square blockade right this
is the easy one
if you can get the pawns on the other
color complex then you can just blockade
and it doesn't matter how many pawns
there are you're not
breaking through well it doesn't matter
how many pawns there are but
with two puns you're not breaking
through okay shouldn't have said it
doesn't matter how many pawns there are
because sometimes things get weird
but okay with two puns this is always a
draw so now let's move on
pawns now they're one file apart what's
different
is it still a draw is it the same kind
of draw how do we pressure the pawns
like this
what do you what's going on here
what is the evaluation of this position
at which rank is it too late um it's
sort of never
too late i think i mean obviously if
there's a pawn on the second rank then
it's a bit too late because you can't
really attack it from the front
because your bishop is on the first and
then the pawn takes it
if the pawn's on the third rank
i think that's still a draw i'll have to
i'll have to double check
i will double check though
what if black has three connected pawns
that's outside the scope of this lecture
okay three pawns that's too many we
can't talk about that
but no it should be winning for the side
with three pawns um
except in rare circumstances when you
can i think again
get some some good blockades
so yeah of course this is a draw and
this is i think the easiest
draw for the opposite colored bishops
aside from you know
one pawn why is this so much easier
than when the pawns are connected well
of course with the pawns
disconnected the pawns are actually
unable to support each other advancing
through this these light squares right
with the pawns together they can at
least help each other get past the light
squares
but with the pawns apart you know this
is as easy as it gets
for the defender so what's the drawing
technique
tell me the easiest drawing idea
for white here
easiest drawing idea it's so simple it's
so simple
bishop d3 is being suggested don't let
the pawns promote sacrifice the bishop
king on do you want to do nothing
so not quite not quite in my opinion the
easiest i think you know it's pretty
hard to lose these positions
but the absolute simplest thing you can
do is put the king on a light square
between the pawns same color as your
bishop would be a dark square if the
bishops were reversed
and then here's what you do you put your
bishop here
and now now you can't lose now you can't
lose
so let's say it's illegal to take the
pawns again unless like they put you in
check right
let's say you were just forced to pass
forever and ever and ever
allowing black to get all the way up the
board it still doesn't matter
it still doesn't matter right he comes
all the way over here thinking he's
going to threaten f3
you just guard f3 you guard d3
and black can just never make progress
you can just stand
firm on this uh on this square and this
is about as simple as it gets to be
honest
so questions on this one file apart end
game i want to spend very little time
here because
it's just that simple does anybody
understand uh
anybody not understand why this is just
the easiest draw of all time you just go
king e2
and then use the bishop to cover
whichever square the black king is also
attacking
it's that easy
everybody understands everybody
understands
so yeah the same color in between and
then you can use the bishop
to help guard as needed
when wouldn't you be able to capture
unless they put you in check so i'm
obviously that was just
for demonstration purposes you would
always be able to capture
in a real game i was just kind of
showing that
no matter where the pawns are no matter
where the black pieces are this idea is
always going to be drawing
for white so even if you allow black to
do anything that black wanted to do
as long as you have the king on e2 and
you can control the other squares with
the bishops
with the bishop then you're fine by the
way it would also work from this
direction
just chose this because it was a bit
longer okay let's move on then
two files apart so what do we think
about two files of parts
two files aparts things are getting a
little bit crazy
things are getting a little bit crazy
here so two files apart
now now what's happening right the all
the rules we thought we knew the
connected pawns attacked from the front
what does it all mean
it does doesn't matter here
patrick says winning but he's just
guessing keynes is still a draw
randall says some winning easy draw
white wins
white wins oh my gosh drawish this is
winning
winning maybe drawing and yes so this
one is the borderline
in almost every scenario this is going
to be a win
for black by the way i should add the
caveat at this point
that's um always going almost always a
win for black
with the caveat that if one pawn is the
wrong color rook pawn
then of course those positions tend to
be drawn right those positions tend to
be drawn like let me just flip over to
this
right you know black's pawns super far
apart no way the bishop can influence
both at the same time
but this pawn queen's on a light square
white can put the king here
and then just sack this bishop for the
the a pawn whenever necessary so
all of these puzzles from here on out
with the caveat that this doesn't work
if it's a rook pawn okay it
does does not work so
let's look here um
in this position black is actually
totally
totally winning and there's really only
one rare circumstance that i could find
in uh with the puns and the cnf files
that results in
white drawing so let's take a look at it
let's take a look
so how does white win in this or how
does black win in this position well
first of all let's look at how white can
potentially draw
so white can potentially draw
if he's able to influence both pawns at
the same time
with the bishop with the pawns one file
apart we saw that the king was actually
able to influence both pawns at the same
time
and this is why white could easily draw
with the pawns
together we saw that the bishop could
again
influence both pawns at the same time
thanks to the fact it could control the
square in front of this pawn
and attack this pawn at the same time so
white's drawing ideas
sort of always focus on this idea of
influencing both
pawns at the same time with one of one
of white's pieces
so that idea holds true in this position
unfortunately if black plays well white
should be unable
to set up some kind of position where he
influences both pawns at the same time
he sort of has to dedicate one piece to
one pawn
and one piece to the other pawn and it's
very difficult to move between the two
so how can white influence both at the
same time
well for example if bishop d3 were to be
played
and something like bishop e7 now the
position
is actually a draw why
on earth is this position a draw well
white has successfully set up a position
where you can influence both
pawns at the same time and the white
king is going to be getting there faster
than
the black king so how is this possible
well
white has put this bishop on a very
particular diagonal
where it can control two different
squares on the c and f files
at the same time without you know
removing the bishop from this diagonal
so
this bishop at the same time can both
stop the f
pawn and stop the c pawn by sort of
relegating them
to the same file here and the second
part that i mentioned
is that the king is getting there first
which means that after king e3
king e6 king f4 white is just in time to
stop black
from getting to this f5 square if black
if white were to be a little bit more
nonchalant than
king e5 or just f5 directly and
this idea no longer works because white
doesn't have this plan
of influencing both pawns at the same
time
so this position believe it or not is
actually
a draw now black has no way to advance
because
together the bishop is going to stop
both pawns at the same time
and whenever the king runs around to try
and support the other pawn
the white king will retreat and
successfully stop the black king
from pushing that pawn forward so this
is a pretty strange looking idea but if
you understand
that in the first two end games white is
drawing because he can use one piece to
stop both pawns at the same time
then this makes a little bit more sense
white is drawing here
because he uses one bishop to stop both
pawns at the same time
and then the kings sort of cancel each
other out as we go so let's just take a
look at how it actually happens
let's say check now white to move and
draw we of course
still have to stop f5 so king g4 is a
reasonable idea king g5 also draws
now king e5 and it looks like you know
things are pretty bad for white
but actually we can just go bishop h7
and no matter how hard we try
to advance the c pawn it's not going to
matter here
king e5 for example king f3 c3
king e2 would actually lose because it
allows f5
but if we pass with bishop c2 now if the
king steps this way
we step to f2 and
as soon as what black is about to
support c2
we come and stop him it comes back the
other the other way
we also come back the other way and
white can somehow on this one light
square diagonal with this king
stop f5 and c2 and black is just unable
to make progress notably
this bishop is effectively not playing
right this bishop is is going to be used
to to defend the pawns
and that's about it so this is the only
real drawing
idea for white setting these pawns up on
the same diagonal
so that he can use the king on this
other diagonal to
to support the the bishop and stop the
pawn so this is a pretty strange idea
but does everybody understand
what's going on here why can't we say
the same for the h1a8 diagonal
you could but it's just impossible to
set this up right because c5 is always a
legal move
so you can't really make a strong hold
on on c6
right because the pawn can just sort of
leap frog over that square
so it just turns out that this is the
more achievable diagonal to set it up on
this is just the more
achievable diagonal to set it up on
on f1 c4
so yes but then the problem is
this is a good question thank you for
bringing this up the problem is you see
this idea
where we use our king to run back and
forth on the diagonal behind the bishop
obviously there is no diagonal behind
the bishop from um
well actually there is right ah but okay
the problem is
with the bishop on c2 in this case uh
with the pawn coming to c2 in this case
we need the
king to come behind it with king d1 with
the pawn on f2
we would need the king to come behind it
to e0
and that square just does not exist so
due to that square not existing
white cannot draw from the f1 c4
diagonal
the pawn on f2 if the king makes its way
around to g2
we don't have any king d1 idea to
successfully
stop the king from influencing that pawn
that is a great question
thank you
how does black win well black wins by
not allowing white to put the pawns on
the same diagonal like this and really
that turns out to be a pretty simple
task for uh for black
so yeah great question on the f1 c4
diagonal but yes
because on this diagonal we need the
king to be able to step to d1
to stop c2 on this diagonal we would not
have an e0
square for the king to stop f1
queening right it's sort of like if you
imagine king d1 wasn't legal here
we'll just set it up um king d1 is not
legal
in this case now all of a sudden here
king d3
is allowing f5 right you can't go king
d1 and there's no other way to stop
the king from getting to c2 okay
let's move on to how black can win
so how can black win well of course
after something like bishop d3
we should just activate our king right
king e7 king d7 either
think would work let's say king d7 king
e2
king e6 king e3 and white is not in time
to set up this blockade
because black can play either f5 or king
e5 here
let's say f5 now of king of f4 of course
it would get checked away
and so let's see how
uh black can try to win if white is just
sort of naively
playing along here right let's say
bishop a6 now of course
after something like c5 well okay i'm
hanging upon so bishop
bishop d6 first bishop f1 and c5
right now it's pretty clear how black is
actually winning the game
right white is unable to influence both
pawns at the same time
and so black is going to be able to push
the pawns and that's kind of
the end of the story right let's say
something like
you know i almost can't make moves at
this point c4
bishop back c3 bishop here the king can
wrap its way around now
let's say white tries to defend
something like this
coming to d1 for example but now of
course
black to move and win we have f3 bishop
cannot stay on both pawns at the same
time
bishop check f2
and the game is coming to a close here
so i thought that was you know i always
thought that was like the end of the
story right two two files apart white
can't influence both at the same time
and that's
that's that black wins unless white gets
this crazy
diagonal setup and then you know as i
sometimes do i decided to uh to put it
to the test a little bit
and tried to win it against the computer
and
it gave me a lot more problems than i
was realizing so sort of in my head
this was where i was going to to end on
the the two files of part lecture
and say yeah okay and so black should
win and then i tried it against the
computer and the computer makes
everything so so difficult
so let's see what this looks like
against you know relatively perfect play
from the engine let's see if it's
actually so easy right so this is
now a game national master the llama
lord against leeches
ai level eight scary scary stuff
so in the game the lyches a tried bishop
c4 first
deviously attacking my pawn i play king
e7
activating the king king f2 f5
king e3 king f6 and now
uh bishop b5 was played of course you
can't really stop the pawn from getting
to f4 because it's a dark square
i go king e5 activating the king king d3
i go bishop c5 activating the bishop
bishop a6 and i've just pushed the pawn
down to f4
bishop b7 now is trying to influence
both pawns on the same diagonal
great stuff but of course this is not a
drawing idea
because i can sort of skip over the c6
square because i'm a cheater and pawns
can move two squares
on their first move so rather than play
c5 immediately
i tried to get my king in front of it
and the game continued though king c3
finally c5 and now after bishop b2 check
king 2 c6 bishop f3 check king to d6
king to d3 and it turns out it's not as
so
not as simple as i thought right so in
the previous position that i looked at
black's king kind of just came crashing
through the center and split the white
pieces
and white was was helpless but here
things are a little bit different
against
you know computer play the computer has
actually managed to set its own king up
in the center with this bishop
influencing this diagonal
now behind the pawn not in front of the
pawn and it's not so easy
to continue with black so
how do you actually win this game with
black how do you make progress here
because in the example i was first
showing it was a bit easier right you
just kind of came through the middle
but here white is is sort of playing
playing a bit tougher right white is
stopping you from coming through the
middle
so how can you make progress
how can you make progress
so there's two competing ideas one idea
is to go
this way with the king and one idea is
to go
this way with the king so which way
is better
which position
is better
so of course we should in this case
bring our king over
to the g3 square why is that well it's
because
for the moment the white king is the one
that's committed to
the c4 square and so it's a bit easier
to get in on the king's side than the
queen side what would happen if we went
to the queen side
well unfortunately i think it would just
be a little bit tough
to make any progress let's say he
attacks our pawn
comes back comes up rather even king b6
king c4
king a5 bishop d1 and all of a sudden it
looks like we're kind of getting boxed
right we can sort of pass but now king
b3
and once again we're sort of getting
boxed out right even bishop f3
check and what's that we are right back
where we started
are we not are we not right back where
we started
we're almost back where we started but
but yeah so the king side
is the easier side to get into because
that is the side bishop's on
and that the king is not so king e5 i
think is the best way to continue
now we i brought my king over to the
king side
successfully got to g3 and now the rest
is sort of history
f3 f2 bishop d5 and now
bring the king over this away c
uh c4 c5 or sorry c4 c3
um and yeah by the way did i do this the
best that i could
i'm actually not so sure now in the
process of giving this lecture
i've come to doubt my own my own thing
here but yeah i think i did fine
so the king comes around and
now after c4 c3 it just becomes sort of
trivial
right king comes around again all the
way over to the king's side
and not the greatest technique ever but
we do eventually get the queen
and win the game so what happened there
well once again
i the king had to come to the the queen
side
and so i come to the king side and win
the game
so this is what it sort of looked like
against perfect play i doubt human
opponents
are going to put up as doubt of
resistance
but the computer managed to do this
interesting thing where it put its king
in the center
and the only thing you have to remember
then is that you have to
walk all the way around to the side
where the king isn't to to make progress
hopefully that was
a little bit clearer but still a win
for black with good play right just
bring the king around
to the side where the other king isn't
took some doing in the actual game but
we got there in the end
and i did manage to win queen versus
bishop believe it or not
so okay that is two files apart
what happens with three files apart
three files apart okay
resets every pawn push so yeah no
worries about the 50 move rule here
uh the entire game in this case took me
71 moves but that 50 move rule resets
every time you you move upon forward so
every time you make progress
the 50 move roller sets let's take a
look though at three files
so of course three files is much like
two files but it is
even harder for the uh computer to put
up any kind of resistance
even if it tries to uh you know tries
its best
why is that well because with as the
pawns get further and further apart
it's more and more difficult for the the
two pieces
to influence both pawns at the same time
and in this case i think it is
in fact just impossible right
uh should just be impossible because
for example this is
theoretically the longest diagonal that
white could have let's say the pawns
were on b7 and
f7 this is the longest diagonal white
could have to influence both pawns at
the same time
and you run into this issue where the f1
square doesn't have an e0 square
once again and black would would in fact
be winning so
these games just always going to be
wanting and to prove it i played
the lead chess stockfish again here we
go this is what happened in this game
brought the king up in front of the
pawns
and eventually started pushing with the
king and brought uh
wait a second is this what happened in
the game
yeah wait a second i just assumed
i just assumed it was all so easy
apparently this position is drawn
wait a second i'm so confused
i'm so confused all right this will take
more investigating
so we will leave three files apart alone
for now
i thought that was just an easier
version of two files apart but
apparently
this position was actually drawn and
leeches stockfish just messed it up
so give me some time on that check a
follow-up lecture next week i don't want
to try to do
these things on the fly because then i'm
viable to say something wildly incorrect
so three files apart apparently this is
like randomly a draw and that doesn't
make any sense to me that flies in the
face of everything i thought i knew
about these opposite colored bishop end
games
but okay tune in next week i will uh
get back to you on that interesting
probably it's a draw because my king
can't get around the bishop
right there's there's no room on this
side of the board interesting stuff
so let's check out four files apart
because this one i am quite confident
is just as wildly easy as it seems
there's just no way
for the white pieces to interact with
both of these
and to prove it i won very very quickly
against lychee stockfish and i'm
absolutely certain i didn't mess this
one up anyway
absolutely certain so you just bring the
king up and the king is over here the
bishop's over here it's just so
so easy so five files apart
also really really easy provided it's
not the wrong rook pawn
again the further apart the pawns become
the easier it becomes
unless it's three files apart and then
there's this weird
scenario where sometimes it's a draw
which i'll get back to you on
but then once again the wrong rook pawn
is the easiest draw of all time
if one of the pawns left is the wrong
rook pawn in this case
h7 not a7 then of course the king needs
only to come to this corner
and the bishop needs only to get
to a diagonal where it can stop the pawn
from promoting and the game is going to
be a draw
so
there you go
there you go okay
it's a win unless you play stock fish
apparently it's a win if you do play
stock fish but stockfish
is not always playing the best moves
because it didn't it managed to mess it
up and i won the game anyways
very very strange but okay wrong rook
pawn always going to be a drawn
that's as easy as it comes and then with
the last 20 minutes
i want to take a look at a very
particular end game
between magnus carlsen and hikaru
nakamura
and this is an end game that of course
as we were discussing
was an opposite colored bishop end game
so let's take a look at it and see if
our knowledge
that we learned in earlier in the
lecture comes in handy in this game
now this stuff is not an end game so i
don't care about it
moving along pieces coming off the board
and wait up okay
opposite colored bishop end game so how
do we feel
about this opposite colored bishop end
game how do we feel
about what's going on here
should black win should white draw
what do we know
six files apart is a draw randle has
that one right six files apart always a
draw
always draw
came late so you don't know fair enough
fair enough manny says should be a draw
and the answer is
nobody knows you kind of have to go
through a little bit more of the game
so there is a tactic in this initial
position for
magnus i don't know if you can really
call it a tactic just a positional
threat
that sort of wins another pawn by force
right
so due to the setup around the white
king bishop e2
actually totally entombs this king back
on g1
and if white leaves the king entombed
then of course white is going to lose
you know giving black an extra king is
is going to win in the end game
so white has to play f4 to give the king
the f2 square
so it can actually evacuate so now of
course
magnus has the opportunity to play g
takes f3 going up another pawn
so really you know this end game isn't
the one i should be asking about it's
this end game so bishop f2
is how karu starts d3 bishop b1 king g7
king f2 king f6
king e3 and here we are
in in this end game and once again
should black be winning this yes or no
it's a difficult question
to answer so we know from the lecture
earlier
that with these two pawns one file apart
it's going to be very very difficult to
actually win
with these two pawns alone so what does
that tell us well that tells us
black has to do something about some of
these other pawns if
black is able to actually win one of
these other pawns and then black of
course
would have very good winning chances so
to start off with magnus goes king f5
we see h3 trying to keep the king out
from
invading and capturing the h2 pawn and
now
h5 to keep this pawn at bay
for hikaru as well bishop d2 bishop f1
bishop b1 and now magnus has a decision
does he trade this pawn for this pawn of
course white wasn't interested in taking
an f3
because then these three pawns would be
more powerful
but now after bishop e1
magnus has to decide does he give up
this e pawn this d-pawn
for this h pawn yes or no
so what is the decision here
what to do give up the h pawn for the e
pawn yes or no
chess king says d3 pawn is the only
reason black is better
patrick wouldn't beshear says yes
king e5 so in the game uh magnus
actually does decide to give up this
this e pawn d-pawn for the h3 pawn now
why is that
well because he saw the future as he
sometimes does
right as he sometimes does so
what's the future of this of this game
well he realized
that he can actually trade the f7 pawn
for the f4 pawn
so essentially what he's doing is he's
taking
this 2v0 in the center and moving it
over to the king's side now why does
that matter
well of course by moving it over to the
king's side
these pawns are further away from the
queen side pawns
right and because these pawns are
further away from the queen side pawns
it's like this um this hierarchy that we
saw earlier in the lecture
where the farther apart the pawns get
the the harder it is to draw
right the easier it is to win the harder
it is to draw the further apart the
pawns get
because the bishop is less effective at
influencing both sides of the board
at the same time and that's going to be
the problem that
magnus tries to impose on a karma
nakamura so he trades the h3 pawn for
the d3 pawn
because as we see in the game
um he's able to play f5
and he's going to want to follow this up
with f4 in order
to trade off these pawns and then he'll
have the h
pawn and the f pawn remaining how does
this actually work
well if f4 and bishop f4 look out
because you're allowing h4
and it sort of doesn't matter that white
still has this g pawn on the board
because you cannot take because the
bishop would hang if you move the bishop
now all of a sudden you are just losing
thanks to
this idea so f4 successfully trades
those pawns
right because after gf4
this f pawn again is going to
essentially be irrelevant so magnus is
trading the d-pawn
for the h-pawn for this reason as we see
in the game
now in the game hackard played sort of a
pretty bad move
which is b3 putting this pawn
in front i think the better triforum was
a3
but let's just see what happens in in
the game here so b3 is played
bishop d5 by magnus bishop d6
we see f4 gf4 h4
now in order to stop this pun from
queening white felt the need to play h5
king takes f5 was played king e3 king g4
pass pass h3 king e3
bishop e4 king f2 bishop b1
forces the pawns up now bishop f7
and guess what happened in this
position here what happened in this
position here
because h1 is a light square so yes h1
is a light square so is d1
but the relevant factor here is that the
h pawn is so
far away from the queen's side compared
to
the d-pawn so once again white's king
and white's bishop aren't going to both
be able to stop these pawns
and influence the queen side at the same
time and this is the winning idea for
magnus
carter resigned so yeah i'm pretty sure
carter resigned in this position this is
the end of the game
believe it or not but let's talk about
why how does magnus actually win the
position
how do you actually win this position
how do you win this position chat room
do you see
do you see the winning idea
put the bishop on g4 and run the king
okay what if i play king g3
bishop c5 bishop g1 what happens then
stopping both pawns with my bishop
what happens if i play king g3 attacking
the bishop on g4
and then to stop you from queening i go
bishop c5
bishop g1 huh
what then what then smart chat
what then
so you guys are off to a good start but
let's say i play bishop c5
bishop h5 i pass king here
king g3 bishop g4 bishop g1
how do you win how do you win
yeah chess king says i'm a liar says i'm
a liar maybe he's right
maybe he's right
and yes black to move and win here king
e4
with the point that this bishop is only
pseudo stopping both pawns
f2 or h2 and then the other pawn is able
to queen
and unfortunately for this bishop it
cannot move like a king
and cannot play bishop g2 there are some
variants of chess where the bishop is
allowed to move one square to the left
sometimes like once per game to switch
colors but
no such luck here this bishop cannot
stop that pawn
only the king is able to do that and
unfortunately
for white that is not going to be enough
but i have a question right carter
played this pretty weird move
right car played b3 here and in my
opinion b3 is making things a bit too
easy
so what if cairo had played
a3 does this change anything well let's
think
okay let's say f4 again gf4 h4 again
f5 um
although let's say you know white passes
first to
induce h3 then f5
king f5 right let's say we get this
let's say we get this right king e3
is this position also winning or
not or not see if you guys can figure it
out here
so okay kathlon has a question katherine
catherine maybe katherine chesking says
winning
arianes is winning are you certain
are you certain
navi says draw kane says we can still
take those pawns
maybe
so what's different well what's
different is this backwards pawn is now
on b2 and the backwards pawn is not on
a3
so how does this change things well
might have some ideas now of playing
bishop b5 to keep this b2 pawn a little
bit sturdier
so let's say you get everything you want
right king g4 has to be played to
reroute the bishop so king f2
bishop back i pass bishop here i pass
king f5 i go here bishop g4 king d3
star bishop before i i pass king here i
pass king d3 i go bishop b5
how are you winning the game okay maybe
i don't go bishop b5 maybe i go
here king c2 i go bishop b5
how do you actually win
okay some interesting ideas in the chat
h2f2 doesn't quite win h2f2 i i take and
go king g2
right i mean this is not quite the same
this is not quite the same
this king is not a bishop it can go to
g2 it can i promise
i promise so
if this then i think white would pass
with bishop d4
darth vader says you don't win this
uh so chess king has a pretty
interesting idea so what if
bishop here we go this away
what happens then well king f2
right it was a good idea it's a good
idea but if you go here then then this
is great
then this is great we pass f2 takes
h2 we win in glory takes
takes and bam extra bishop for black
that's great
but what if here what if here what if
king f2
not so easy not so easy chet you thought
you had it
you thought you had me figured out but
king f2
not so easy
so how do you win
how do you win get the king to e2 you
can't i won't let you
sorry i won't let you king d3 king f2 of
course
i won't let you get there you can't you
can't get there i say no
i say no so chat nobody
has come up with the winning idea yet
nobody has come up with the winning idea
and there's no zigzag because the bishop
is free to move here the bishop would be
free to move
king c2 and h2 we were just there
oh wait yo yes so you guys are you guys
are are getting the right idea then so
of course the winning idea is to trade
once again your two pawn advantage for a
different two pawn advantage
so king d3 king f2 king c2
bishop e5 and then either immediately
or a little bit later on the idea is to
go h2
and this idea at first looks a little
bit absurd you're giving up this random
eight this h3 pawn
your powerhouse but of course the idea
is that now your extra pawn is a b
pawn and these pawns are super far
apart whereas these two pawns were only
one file apart
and white is going to be helpless to
stop the b-pawn
whereas white was very able to stop this
h-pawn so
h2 the winning move in this position
and i think this is the only idea that
wins i looked at this end game for quite
a bit
and this is the only way that i found
for uh for white to
for black to end up winning this
position so really cool idea here using
these principles that we learned
where one file apart and connected puns
are often drawn
but if the pawns are super far apart
then the opposite colored bishop is
going to be helpless to stop them so
h2 the incredible move to win the game
here
with the point that king b2 bishop d6
for example
and black is going to be able to to
break through
a5 b4 and
nothing doing nothing doing for
white so good stuff
good stuff what about three files apart
three files apart okay
so i seem to have run into a special
case in the game that i was going to
show with three files apart
and so i will be going over that little
bit again
next week maybe i'll do a follow up with
some more games on opposite color
bishops
but in general three files apart should
be winning assuming you don't run into
one of those special cases
which i didn't think there was really
but apparently
three files apart has its own little
special case here so
with the last few minutes maybe we'll
take a quick look at this which appears
to be a draw
i ended up winning because king a4 was
allowed here
so bishop c6 and apparently though the
black king just never
could get through in this specific case
but
let's see here okay g3 was my mistake of
course
if i advance my king then i should win
and also
bishop g1 and i guess i should win
bishop f1
king g3 should be two king h3
check here and you just you just queen
right
pawns are too far apart this king is
trying to influence both but it just
can't
right it just can't even on e4 it's just
not
powerful enough to influence both pawns
at the same time and so keeping the king
in front of the pawn is always a good
idea in these end games
and black would have won so pawns far
apart black should always win
unless you know you're a fool and you're
playing stock fish and you run into a
special case
in which case you still win because
stockfish doesn't understand the endgame
so there you go
how often do i do these streams i teach
two classes on monday
and three classes on wednesday this is
class two of three on wednesday
and that is why i'm going to call it a
day on these opposite colored bishop end
games
uh i apologize for that slight slip up
with the three files apart end game
but these things happen these are
complicated end games uh
and i spent most of my time on the two
files of part one to be honest with you
i like i thought that was as complicated
as it got i thought once it was three
files apart there were no special cases
but clearly anything can happen so
hopefully you enjoyed uh i'm pretty
confident the rest of the info in this
lecture was 100 correct
just this one special case and three
files apart did not expect it
anyways these things happen if you
enjoyed this lecture please head on
over to twitch where the fun will be
continuing tonight with analyze your
games
it's the class where i analyze your
games
and it's gonna be a lot of fun we do it
every week and i have a good time
looking at what the chats games are
looking like
hopefully they keep getting better and
better and better every week
but that does do it for the endgame
class here tonight so once again
thank you guys so much for watching my
name is killerdenby and i will see you
next time
[Music]
you